okay another r session also on
classification this time we're going to
look at k nearest neighbor
classification
which you know it's one of those tools
it's a very simple classification rule
but it's effective a lot of the time
there's somebody you know some experts
have written that
k-nearest neighbors do the best about
one-third of the time
and it's so simple that if you in the
game of doing classification you always
want to have k-nearest neighbors in your
toolbox
okay so we've got a little session here
that we'll
we'll run
and if we go into our r studio session
we see we've got it set up here for k
nearest neighbors
and for that we'll use the the class
library so we go library class
and that sets us up for
doing k nearest neighbors classification
and let's ask for help on k nearest
neighbors
and we see
the help file which again is always a
useful thing to do
and it tells us it's got a slightly
different format to the previous session
where we used lda
it doesn't take a formula
it asks for the training
x variables the testx variables
and the class label for the training and
then it asks for what value of k you
want and then there's some other
arguments
okay
so we'll use this again on our stock
market example so we'll in this case
we'll
since we're going to have to
list all these variables by name in the
in the call we'll just attach stock
market
and recall when you attach
a data frame it it makes available the
variables on the data frame by name
in your frame so if i go down into the
session window
and say
ls
well
that
didn't do it actually um
i can say objects
um two because stock markets in position
two there we go so they're available in
in location two on the search list and
there's all the variables in
s market available by name
okay
so what we'll do is we'll make a matrix
for of lag one and lag two we're going
to use the same two variables we used in
the previous session so we'll say x lag
is is c bind that makes a matrix with
two columns in this case of lag one and
lag two
okay
and let's just make sure that that
actually did what we want i mean i know
it did but let's look at the first
five rows of that matrix
and there they are so it did what we
wanted
and then we'll make a
we'll make a indicator variable train
which is year less than 2005. so that's
just going to be a binary variable of
trues and falses depending on whether
the variable year was less than 2005.
okay now we're ready to call knn so we
give it our matrix x lag
and right in line here we index it by
train which says just use the training
observations
and
and then for the test observations we
give it x lag not trained so those not
train will be therefore those that
aren't that are equal to 2005 right
for year equal to 2005.
so train and not train that exclamation
mark means not
and the response is direction again
indexed by train and k equals 1 says we
want one nearest neighbor classification
and again just to remind you that means
what the algorithm does is it says to
classify a new observation you go into
the training set
in the in the
in the x space the feature space and you
look for the training observation that's
closest to your test point
in euclidean distance and you classify
to its class
okay
and so this
will do it
and we can look at the we put the
results in k n dot pred and we can do a
table of k n dot pred and the true
response which is direction at not train
and we get a little confusion matrix
again and we can look at the
classification performance there
and it's exactly 0.5
so it was useless one nearest neighbor
did no better than flipping a coin
so
what to do next well
one could proceed further and try
nearest neighbors with multiple
values of k
we haven't done that in this session but
we leave it up to you
and you can look in the end of the the
chapter and you'll see that there's
examples of this